that program was recorded the end of
September six weeks six weeks later we
are live here in our studio with author
David marinus and two of the characters
from his book first let me introduce
Paul Soglin mr. Soglin is 58 years old
he lives in Madison Wisconsin where he
is a consultant in the areas of
administration and finance in the
October 1967 anti-war demonstration he
was this student on the right using his
coat to protect him from the police
batons he was only 17 years old when he
arrived in Madison and in the book
davidmeredith describes him as that
babyface kid too young to drink beer
even in Wisconsin's relaxed standards
Clarke Welch is 63 years old he lives in
the mountains of Colorado eleven miles
from Pikes Peak and one-and-a-half miles
from the nearest paved road he and his
wife Laci are planning to move to
Florida soon at age 27 he was the Delta
company commander on that day in October
1967 when 61 of his men were killed his
men had nicknamed him big rock our phone
lines are open and we'd invite you to
join us we've split our lines this way
this evening if you are over 50 years of
age your number is 202 5 8 5 3 8 9 zero
if you are under 50 years of age we
figure you have a different experience
in remembering the Vietnam War and that
number it for you is 202 5 8 5 3 8 9 1
we've also set one phone line aside for
people who have read the book if you
would like to call in and ask questions
you can do it this way 202 5 8 5 3 8 9 2
gentlemen thank you for joining us this
evening
David Barrett thank you this is the
first time that these two characters in
your book have met yeah it's quite an
experience to have them here together
and it really is what the book is all
about and over the last five weeks as
I've been on a book tour almost
everywhere I've gone there have been
soldiers from this battle and people who
were at Wisconsin in 1967 so this is the
culmination of that Paul Soglin let's
start with you
how did October 1967 change your life it
probably woke me up in the sense that it
was gonna be a long
a long difficult effort to change the
war in Vietnam it reinforced something I
was already concerned about which was
those of us who are students on the
campus protesting the war were very
isolated from a larger community and and
a larger number of Americans and it sort
of reinforced my commitment to continue
opposing nor you went on to be a
politician as Dave notes in the book six
months later I was elected to the City
Council representing an area that was
predominantly students living off of
campus and six years after that I was I
was elected mayor like well how did
October 1967 change you how did you deal
with it on a day-to-day basis it's in
very with great difficulty it was but
for me then a terrible day and it
confirmed my worst fears about the
things that were wrong with the army and
wrong with the government nothing wrong
with my soldiers and when when I
recovered from the wounds it was resting
in the hospital and had more time to
think about it the only way I could
handle it was almost to blanked it out
so I never forgot it not a day goes by
that I don't think about it but for many
many years until David started doing his
research on the book it was a blanked
out just let it go it's too hard I can't
fix it it's too bad but I think about it
every day every day do the phone calls
go ahead Marion Indiana hello hello my
name is Marita Galloway and first of all
to mr. Welsh I want to say thank you
very much and welcome home but I work
with Vietnam veterans at a VA hospital
trying to help them deal with
post-traumatic stress disorder and I was
wondering if you have had any problems
in that area any treatment
I'm not sure exactly what medical
problems I've had of course I've had
problems with it the best treatment I've
had is David David doing the research
for the book he really would not have
had to have published the book but when
David did the research and uncovered all
of my other soldiers and found them and
is able to tell me where they were and I
was able to let them know where I was
and they knew I knew where they were and
being able to come to grips with what
really happened at what what I thought
happened is what's in the book all my
soldiers memories are correct that's
been the best treatment for it I think
all of my soldiers anybody that was
involved in a hard part of it suffers
from or has that syndrome but talking
about it now and knowing that the truth
is out is the way to fix it Tucson
Arizona hello Connie I wanted to thank
you for doing this show this is a
fabulous show and thank you and thanks
to c-span welcome that's it this one is
Madison Wisconsin my name is Jim Kurtz
I'm a veteran of the 1st Infantry
Division and I was also at the doll riot
both sides of the bush both sides what
do you what's your question this evening
well my question is is what can we learn
about what's going on right now in the
Iraq area where people aren't really
supporting what's happening with our
troops and I was an early veteran I was
there before Scott and before before the
you know before the riot and all of that
and I also had a chance to vote for mr.
Soglin what I like to know what their
comments are mr. Soglin you started well
first of all I want to I want to say one
thing I've been wanting to say really
since you first planned this which is
just it's an honor it's a it's a
pleasure to to meet Clark because of who
and what he is and also because of the
the soldiers that he represents I asked
Dave as soon as I finished the book how
do the soldiers out of the GI s-- feel
about us I have tremendous admiration
for for their story and what they did
and I want to say that in light of
what's happening in in Iraq I'm very
fearful that we're going down the same
path again the the intelligence
reporting is is not accurate we don't
understand the situation we're in we
confuse in this country foreign
governments with nan and then the
nationalist interest of people that was
part of part of our problem Vietnam I'm
afraid it's part of our problem in Iraq
and I think we've got two problems we
have to deal with now one is our
national problem of what do we do in
Iraq but we have a second problem which
is we've got a lot of men and women in
Iraq that we've got to bring home safely
sooner rather than later
Clark Welch aye aye I try not to think
too much about Iraq because it is very
confusing to me and my I spent my life
with these kind of things when somebody
would ask me a question like that I
would spend a few minutes or a few hours
or a few days figuring out what I
thought the correct answer wasn't and I
damn well went outside and started to
work on it now I'm in a position where I
talk about it and I don't talk about it
very well and I excuse myself that I I
don't really know what's going on but
it's very confusing to me and I'm very
concerned about our that they as Paul
says and I absolutely believe what he
said and that we we the soldiers I can't
speak for all the soldiers but my guys
have no certainly no animosity towards
Paul today and 36 years ago probably
thought what Jesus Christ
that could have been me if I'd been on
campus them I would have been doing
something I worry about the kids I worry
about the kids I do not understand what
we're up to
would it really have been you if you had
been at the University of Wisconsin in
1967 I would have done something I do
not know what I would have done with the
experience I've been in 67 I've been in
Special Forces for ten years I truly
believed in and you know the president
said to go somewhere do something in my
case fight I would have been just as
pleased to go somewhere build buildings
and go somewhere in fixed cornfields but
in my mind what I was good at what I
enjoyed doing
it's always very lucky when you're good
at what you like doing the president
sent us the places and we would fight
later on when I came back on campus I
felt no need to either be for or against
much of anything if I had had if I had
just come out of high school and gone to
the campus I would have gone something I
do not know and I've had people tell me
and I've said said that I could have
easily been a hippie in times when I've
been around those kind of people are
kind of like them I've never
particularly liked the government or
worked for the government but I don't
like the government I could have done
with him I could have been with them you
know back Beck's just maybe a year or so
before all the events took place in this
book I remember with some roommates
discussing the the fact that not only
was the war horrible in the sense of
what was happening in the Vietnam
happening to our soldiers happening to
the Vietnamese people but I was
concerned that it was forever I'm going
to split our generation that it was
going to have lasting consequences
because of the tremendous bitterness and
it has to a great degree defined
American politics for the last 30
35 years but also what I've what I've
come to learn is that for many of us
whether we were protesters or we're
soldiers or police officers for that
matter because later as mayor I I was
being protected by police officers who
were on the other side and
demonstrations I came to learn more that
had to do with certain shared values and
that their us say frankly there were
some people who were protesting then who
then I found pretty repugnant and I find
even more distasteful today and there
are certainly veterans and it doesn't
matter whether or not they were with
vets against vets for peace or anything
like that but they're their veterans I
find I have a lot more in common with
than some of the former protesters to
our viewers also if you cannot get in by
telephone and you'd like to email a
question and you can go to WWE org or
you can also just email us at book TV at
c-span org is this what you just heard
example of what your book was talking
about the fact that these these lines
are blurred I'm delighted to just sit
back and listen to these two that
Clerkenwell talk it's part of what the
mission of the book was not that define
I mean I really just wanted to tell the
stories but if there was something
underlying the book it was to try to
find the commonality in the human
endeavor among people as different as as
Paul and Clark and the only thing that I
would add to that is that I believe
deeply in in human beings facing the
situations as they're presented to them
in life and Clark Welch faced the
situation that he came up with he was a
great soldier Paul Soglin was against
the war served humanity in a different
way in the end as being a mayor and a
public servant for many many years and
that's a value to to the common good as
well and people should remember both of
those from our over 50
Scranton Pennsylvania go ahead yes I
want to talk to Rock Jack Brennan from
Scranton I was in a golf to to secretary
February 1st Marine Division and the and
Tet Offensive that's one of the way I
got wounded that Purple Heart I have a
lot of respect for you and all ultimen
that served and I still got issues you
know Paul very nice guy but I I put him
up there with Jane Fonda you know I'm
still working on this but I never did it
feels it feels better not to have him
him with them I'll give you all my kids
have been in the service I got one just
come out of Marines he's having a hard
time right now finding a job I have one
was on the Nimitz he was in the Navy I
had a son son in the army
so the Navy the Army in a Marine Corps
had three boys they follow me because I
was the typical for working-class
Vietnam veteran and they needed a
couldn't afford family you know that's
how we did we all I was one of five
brothers and all of us went in the
military that's how I ended up in
Vietnam and I'm saying what my kids I
never made big bucks came back work this
small town and so when it came time for
dinner I said hey you know college too
high you can go on the grants or student
loans and stuff but I'd recommend you
put two or three years in the military
and that's what they all did now they're
all I got one's a teacher they're all
they're all like graduating you know
hopefully I still got want to just got
out but they took advantage so that GI
Bill I call inaudible Gummer evil thank
you anyway the is he on their issues no
I'm sorry he's not okay oh great lost
him I'd I would say thank you for your
service and your patriotism it says it's
hard to be in the service
Jasper Alabama
hello mr. Clark Welch yes my name is Don
tittle I'm young man I was born 1964 and
as a young man in the early 70s I was
you know sitting watching TV when all
this was unfolding at the end my son is
10 now and he sees the war in Iraq I
said well son I got to see me at Nam now
you're saying Iraq but to you mr. Clark
Welch I want to say thank you for a job
well done
thank you god bless you and I wear it in
my a bracelet I never need a guy who's
on the bracelet I helped the pill WMI
families and why this man's bracelet and
I hope someday he comes home thank you
thank you being a service thank you
Highland Park Illinois yes first I'd
like to thank David for writing this
book I think he described his interview
was with Clark as a chilling experience
and I got goosebumps reading the book
repeatedly he talked about one of his
purposes being to honor soldiers and the
honor descent and I think that's
consistent with the sifting and
winnowing spirit of the University of
Wisconsin I have a question for for
David um a sense that you chose to mark
represent the Vietnam cited story and
Paul to represent the medicine side why
did you choose them why Clark for
example as opposed to Allen or hinder or
Hollander and why white David sorry
appalled as opposed to maybe Evans or
Colin or even Sewell those are good
questions as you'll know in the book
there are a couple of hundred characters
in the book
and certainly Terry Allen is a major
character but it's Clarke Welch who
carries the book from the beginning to
the end and Paul on the Wisconsin side
and I would say it's because I think
that they are both very interesting
stories and I knew that I can take them
from the beginning to the end I couldn't
take Terry Allen
that awful day because he was killed
that day Clark was the leader of one of
the companies in the battle he was a
hero in in the battle and what happened
to him afterwards was fascinating all
the way through with our trip to Vietnam
but all of the the truck the
difficulties that he had after that day
dealing with with life and the
government and the military and all of
that so I saw him to be emblematic in
many ways of of a good soldier in a
difficult situation for Paul he was sort
of was the the character who was in the
building that day who most clearly came
out of it determined to try to affect
politics in America and was successful
in to the extent that he was elected to
the City Council and then mayor for all
those many years and so I thought he
would be the most interesting character
to follow on that side Albertson New
York go ahead yes my name is Don Moran
and I have a question for mr. Meredith I
was an undergraduate in 1967 at the
University of Buffalo and I experienced
a similar police riot at beating for his
similar to mr. soglin's experience
myself and you know we were aware of a
few other demonstrations at Columbia and
Berkeley we had no idea what has
happened at the University of Wisconsin
and I was wondering if there was either
yourself or another author I was
interested in chronicling really what
happened in universities throughout the
United States not just you know isolated
in in Wisconsin I'd like to hear your
thoughts on that I think there are a few
books that deal with the history of the
anti-war movement based largely on
college campuses during that period I've
certainly read I think all of the those
that have been written one just focusing
on college protests I think might be a
fascinating book
in Wisconsin the other day and and was
getting calls about a protest by black
students in 1968 at Ashe Kosh the
University of Wisconsin Oshkosh and
that's sort of like a great story in and
of itself where the student protesters
were sent off to jails all over
Wisconsin for three weeks nobody knew
where they were there was no record of
them so I think there's probably a lot
of the hidden history of that era that
might make it a fascinating book and I'm
sure Paul has some thoughts on that too
there I do know that there's one book
that tried to Chronicle the history of
all the demonstrations the the name
escapes me so I'm not much help in that
regard others say that there is
something out there if you can find a
good search engine then you you had
talked earlier about the fact that you
were isolated I mean the was your
movement isolated is that it did you
ever at that juncture the the anti-war
movement had grown to some degree beyond
the borders of the universities but
really everything was centralized we had
had a student group that had actually
named itself University Community Action
trying to get beyond the the boundaries
of the campus the demonstrations in
sixty-seven along with obviously what
happened leading up to the Democratic
convention clearly showed that this was
now something that went beyond students
Cape Coral Florida go ahead yes I just
want to ask how the generals and the top
echelons of the military seemed to be
conservative in nature and how that
would affect the regular fighting man if
they tended to lean towards the
conservative and powers-that-be in the
Republican Party well what do you think
well I don't think it bodes well that
they would come across as being
all that straight with the American
people
cockroach do you think so I never had
much to do with the general and I I I
don't know I I don't have much to do
with the general often I did not
understand what they were up to
I'd like to add that I think most
generals probably are very conservative
that the general that I know the only
general I really know very well is Jim
Shelton who is the character in this
book a retired general down in Florida
and Jim Shelton is not a conservative
he's a very interesting man who one of
the first conversations I had with him
said he was trying to figure out a way
to get the 82nd airborne hooked up with
a Southern Poverty Law Center because he
thought that would help sort of the
black soldiers identify more with with
the claws Jim Shelton was in the
audience at Texas not too long ago last
weekend when you were there giving a
speech he came through for that speech
and Clark was there and Consuelo Allen
reserves and y'all need to have them and
he had also written a book himself Jim
Shelton is such a generous man that when
I first contacted him to tell him that I
was writing this book I discovered he'd
been working on his own book for
something like 12 years to try to
describe his experience through this
battle and rather than saying to me well
I'm doing my book I don't talk to you he
invited me down and spent on things he
was or was not at the battle itself he
was not have to battle him himself which
was a terrible tragedy that the army saw
fit to remove him from the unit prior to
the battle and Jim Shelton has always
regretted that he was not at the battle
he felt that he could have made a
difference
many of us agree nobody could have made
a difference on the day of the battle we
were just overwhelmed but the days
before the leading up to the battle if
Shelton had remained with the unit he
would have been able to manage the
personal relationships within the
battalion and probably would have made a
difference and he's been driven to write
his book and he was the man who
convinced general Shelton who convinced
me to talk to David Maraniss
which was a turning point in my life and
Jim Shelton was the closest friend that
Terry Allen had in Vietnam the Terry on
the battalion commander and so if
anybody might have been able to persuade
Terry Allen not to do what he did that
day it might have been Shelton but what
was the reason he wasn't there he'd been
promoted he was promoted he was a Jim
Shelton was an X I thought the kind of
the perfect operations officer we had an
excellent commander at Colonel Allen
Hall always clean always we're in
complete uniform looking good all the
time
quiet never told a lie good man and
general Shelton was kind of an a major
was kind of a down in the dirt guy who
would argue with you and he screamed at
me a number of times and I'd yell right
back at him it was a perfect combination
to lead our battalion into a fight the
the quiet calm reserved commander the
the wild man of an operations officer
they worked extremely well together and
I found out since then that they were
very very good friends and when Jim
Shelton left the colonel had no one to
do that with and that kind of left him
open to the things that happened to him
Paul Soglin on your end of it was there
any organization and how was the
organization in the anti-war movement
the students the the organization was
fairly democratic except for the fact
that sometimes as decisions would drag
out late into the night what would
happen is people would vote by with
their feet to go home and consequently
only the most militant people would be
left at 10:00 or 11:00 or midnight to
start making to make decisions again
reaffirm them or whatever so in that
sense there was a lot of self selection
and and that probably raised the level
of militancy
now since that time
considerable experience and
administration and management and taught
courses in administration and I've
looked back on that and I'm kind of
overwhelmed that on the one hand we were
as successful as we were I mean in one
sense within the next six months
Lyndon Johnson said I'm not running for
president and at that point we still had
a great deal of hope until five days
later dr. King is assassinated and then
comes a whole series of incredible
tragedies both domestically and abroad
on the other hand we had so many missed
opportunities there were so many things
we didn't understand we didn't
understand the GIS we didn't understand
the impact we had on leaders real
government leaders like Johnson we
didn't have an appreciation for that and
so if there'd been a stronger group of
older better trained people I think that
in the sense of ending the war we could
have been more effective and Dennard
earlier we have from our line of from
people who have read the book from
Atlanta Georgia
go ahead lad this is Fred Andrew from
Atlanta Georgia
I'm calling I'd like to thank all three
of you Clark from October 1916 well
actually from June 1969 to June 1970 I
was in the 1st Cavalry Division Oh 20
kilometers to maybe 50 kilometers north
and west of you up along the Cambodian
border
Paul incidentally Clarke I was in a
mortar split tools that was allowed to
shoot a terrible tragedy when mortars
when they shoot - very good they shot
the day before for me very well but they
didn't shoot on the day of the battle
well we did quite a bit of shooting I
started out in Charlie Company 2nd
battalion 7th Cavalry Colonel Custer's
old unit and I know them I've heard them
sing their song in the morning Gary
Owens and then I was transferred to echo
company Manor
to stay on the fire bases where you know
as you know about 200 men defended our
sent homes against all sorts of North
Vietnamese Paul I was opposed to the war
in the mid-60s and then when I was
drafted however I felt I did have a duty
to serve my country
most of my parents and most of my
friends had parents who served in World
War two some in Korea and finally David
I thoroughly enjoyed the book I've
gotten out old military maps and I've
got all my battalion daily journals I
could check what you were writing about
because on the same maps I've gotten
from the archives and the the geologic
survey in Colorado thanks very much
thank you thank you of maps well I love
maps I mean I could spend all day just
looking at maps it's important to get
the maps are fairly extra to it I hope
mine are I think they are but they
they're just another way for the reader
to visualize what I try to draw as a
portrait in the book Stanford
Connecticut thank you mr. Welch I want
to repeat the comments an earlier call
or thank you very much your service and
welcome home
thank you mr. Morales the United States
is a tremendous interest still in the
Vietnam War I curate sounds Vietnamese
look at this you were there today cause
in America so they're looking old
battlefield yeah a little bit absolutely
I think Vietnam has the youngest
population in the world if I'm not
mistaken so a vast majority the people
that were born after this American war
as they call it or the war against
American aggression and to the
Vietnamese Clark and I discovered that
they would say that the this war was
just a blip in their history thousand
year history much more interest in their
relationship with China which has been
more difficult over those thousand years
and and really they've they've they've
moved past that war probably more than
the United States has in part because
they won the war next call is Gulf
let me see I'm not sure which is the
next well let's go Gulf Breeze Florida
next to low Gulf Breeze yes I'd like to
say hello to Colonel Welch I worked with
him at Fort Lewis at high technology
testbed and I'm in civil service I have
been I was right out of college whenever
I went to current web with my boss and I
just I've always never forgotten you
you've given me some great leadership
I'm gonna share your name with this
collar my name is Julie I remember you
and I knew exact I recognized you but
I've never forgotten you and I've always
appreciate everything you've taught me
skills and I'm now head of my own
section now and thank you I remember you
very well you were a big help and you
are fun what's it like to have all these
people come out of your past it's
wonderful after 30 years of I don't
wanna sound Woodleigh dramatic but being
afraid to answer the phone thinking that
it might be one of my soldiers who is
finally located and has mad at me
because I was responsible for him
getting his leg blown off and then now
knowing that my soldiers were afraid to
get in touch with me they didn't answer
the phone because they thought I would
call them and be mad at them for not
fighting hard enough and now since at
the Shelton's book and David's book I'm
not afraid to answer the phone when
these people called in and when she says
when she said she knew me it's it's
going to be good so I'm anxious to find
out who she is and I do remember her
it's it it's been good in two ways first
just talking with old friends but also
the book has accomplished a lot of what
they wanted wanted it to do which is
gotten us to thinking and
and really forming new connections I'd
mentioned earlier before that we started
the show I won't go into the details but
I was on the internet and I came across
somebody with a handle of Black Lion 67
and I was just really curious about this
I was too much of a coincidence and so I
sent an email and didn't want to intrude
into this person's life but that got an
email back and Larry McDivitt who had
the awful responsibility of helping to
identify the dead soldiers that day was
on the other end and he and I have been
corresponding now I don't know that
we'll ever vote for the same person for
president he wants Barry Alvarez who's
the Wisconsin football coach but back in
Nebraska we're not gonna agree on that
but we've had some very interesting
communications and correspondence he's
got a son fighting in Iraq it was
stationed in Iraq and so it's it's open
that world I work with a guy now Steve
Dickman and his in my life have pretty
well paralleled one another in terms of
college and law school except I was in
college for three years in graduate
school he spent three years in Vietnam
and he and I spend time now talking
about the differences and the
experiences we've had and I think it it
brings us closer together
from our line of people who have read
the book eastern Pennsylvania um hi my
I'm John Landon and Mike sort of thanks
to the author my father was one of your
characters in the book Gregory Landon I
want to thing is I don't think I would
have heard a lot about that stuff
without your help your dad didn't talk
about it much yeah usually I'm really a
very quiet guy if you know him he
doesn't do that really much of anything
most of the time so he's very secluded
but I really learned a lot from it and I
really thank you for it I learned a lot
from you dad to his nickname in Vietnam
was the professor
he had actually dropped out of Amherst
when he was drafted into the Army and
was one of those who came over on the
ship that Clarke was picked up in Vung
Tau that's and Greg Landon was in
Clarke's company and was wounded that
day and wrote a lot of letters home and
had a very sharp memory that helped me
quite a bit so thank you and thank you
Father this email question David Marin
is do you think the campus anti napalm
protests had an impact on the use of
napalm by the American military in
Vietnam well it actually did and as a
matter of fact a few years later not
long not many years later the military
stopped using napalm in Vietnam in my
book it's right at the point where the
makers of napalm the Dow Chemical
Company in Midland Michigan I discovered
through the documents was having a deep
internal debate about the effects of
this and why they were becoming the sort
of the target for the anti-war protests
as opposed to the military that was
using them and that continued to the
point where eventually they did stop
using it and Clark Welch this question
asked if would the availability of
napalm have reduced the American
casualty toll at the Battle of on phone
no no it was used as shoes but it was a
mile away one of one of the problems
that day that I felt was wrong was we
were bringing artillery in close and you
could bring the artillery in close I had
a a I had a spectacularly proficient and
wonderful young man who brought the
artillery and he was killed that day
Thank You Durham the artillery can come
in real close we could see the our
children Browns coming through the trees
and land and on the ground and the
artillery was very close someone decided
to stop shooting the artillery to bring
in napalm and bombs the bombs and the
napalm were falling 500 meters away a
mile away and my enemy that day was 10
or 20 feet away just from one side of
this room to the other side so on that
day napalm would have made a dead
it it might have scared somebody but
people I was concerned about it the ones
that were with him hang grenade range
Calif all Modesto California yes I
celebrated my 21st birthday in Vietnam
in October on October 7th I was a part
of the 9th Infantry Division we came in
on the heels of the big red one at vung
tau and I feel that the war protesters
helped save the lives of many GIS who
came home who might not have come home
and finally my question to the panel is
do you feel that now we have an
all-volunteer army that it changes the
color of the news reports coming from
Iraq and the idea in general about going
to war or not going to war exit
strategies and so on when we don't have
draftees and don't have the public in an
uproar necessarily
I've I've got serious reservations
believe it or not about an all-volunteer
army as to who is going to volunteer who
is not going to volunteer and again the
the equity I'd like to believe that for
example if we ever found ourselves and
hopefully this will never happen in the
situations we did leading to world war
ii that there would be no shortage of
men and women to serve i know that
there's gonna be a lot of debate about
whether or not the protesters prolonged
the war or the protesters actually
helped save lives
I'm gonna let other people make that
kind of judgment I believe more
importantly we've got to look at what it
is that gets us into war what it is what
are our failures that alternatives to
war
don't don't work but but but there's a
quality in in Clarke Welch that I think
is very important whether we're talking
about somebody who's a mid-level
position making decisions or is all the
way up at the top
and it came out in the book and I've
seen him in interviews talked about this
which is when he's not in a position
where anyone is not in a position to
directly make the decision and control
it if they do have input they have to
figure out how to be effective at it
they have to be have good information
and he has strived I mean it's very
clear in the book that he strived to do
that and he's expressed you know he's
tried to put some I don't know
responsibility on his own shoulders that
he wasn't more effective at that time
that's an extra step that I think real
leaders need to take and it's got to be
the people who are making the decisions
in Washington who are willing to also
take that kind of responsibility in the
decision-making process how in Sandri of
Virginia yes this question is to mr.
Soglin what are the lessons learned of
with respect your experience to civil
disobedience and its potential extension
now into into the 21st century
well for one thing I firmly believe that
that you know protest can be effective
it can be very effective in making
change we've seen a lot of successes and
a whole lot of areas over the years
changes in position regarding investment
in South Africa bringing an end to
apartheid what really we learned in the
anti-war movement from the civil rights
movement there's one short phrase that's
very critical we have to keep the
crazies in check and if I were to put
some responsibility on myself and other
protesters from that era one of our
failures is we weren't always able to
keep the crazies in check and in terms
of the next protest that's got to be
done why weren't there many women at the
leadership of the anti-war movement
you can get me into a story here it was
totally sexist yeah I let me take a
second I'll tell you the story one night
we came home I've never forget it it was
the winter of 1965 1966 we came home and
Jesse and Linda my roommate Justin Linda
were dating and Linda was about seven or
eight of us in the room and she says
does anyone know what was wrong with
this meeting had been about a hundred
hundred and fifty people at the meeting
and we all kind of just you know not the
usual problems with any of these
political meetings and she said this she
said you know every time a man talked he
addressed the previous man who was
speaking every time a woman talked she
addressed the previous speaker so
whenever a man made a statement
following a woman he related back to the
previous male who had spoken and not the
woman and there was early a lesson
learned that night and that lesson began
to evolve over the next two to three
years but it's not until we really get
into the maybe 69 70 and then of course
there's a great deal of leadership among
women at that point I have nothing to
add but I think that it in 67 was before
really the women's movement took hold
and so it did change over the next many
years Columbus Ohio yes today they don't
want to say good job on the book thank
you I know this is of course I can see
you standing there we can all David do
that our clerk one hmm
yes sir one of the plane soldiers who
did what he was told that day I believe
he was wounded he's a good man he stayed
he stayed back while people were getting
out of the jungle he was one of those
who stayed yeah how'd you find him I
found him in one of the reunions as I
recall I think over the course of those
two years that I was getting more and
more contacts and I also had great help
from two of the soldiers who became what
I called my private search engines one
was doc he injured down in Florida and
one was Fred Kirkpatrick in Ohio and
they they really have devoted themselves
to trying to find the other guys who are
in this these units I think we have a
picture of doc hinder from the book he
was at he was a medic during the battle
and well what we say of the medics is
they were standing up when the rest of
us were laying down yeah drama doc
engine was not hurt that day all of my
medics were killed Tom hanger was in the
other company and was not not killed
Madison Wisconsin yeah I was involved in
the protest and the one thing that I
always stuck in my cry was especially
well there was a period there we were
going out every night protesting was
it'd be a point in time where people
would decide was time to start breaking
windows that's when I always went home
any I just thought Paul could made me
comment he made a reference to I was
sitting here waiting to speak about how
the crazies and I think that you know
what kind of affected did those people
that weren't there to make a statement
as much as they were just to smash stuff
and I don't I don't think all of us ever
understand that motivation um but I'm
sure they had has had to have had it
like a huge negative impact on people's
perceptions of the movement did you
continue to protest caller yes I yeah
but like I say well then people started
smashing stuff no go home and I'd be
ready the next day you know all
protesting but when it started to turn
to property destruction I didn't get
connection between mine PI's boots store
and our government sending people to a
war that I felt was illegal Paul Soglin
I I think it hurt in two ways maybe
three ways actually as he repeats the
question first it it turned off many
people that we wished to embrace the
anti-war movement secondly it just took
a tremendous energy out of the rest of
us trying to deal with it rather than
focusing on what was the objective which
is to try to bring a rational end to the
war a speedy end to the war and thirdly
I would imagine it did have a
demoralizing effect on the protesters
themselves that it it made some people
throw in the towel there were two
different groups of crazies one of them
was a very politically committed group
who truly as silly as this may sound
thought that the revolution was around
the corner and we see actually see more
of that in the 70s than we do in the 60s
there were those and then there was a
second group who I always felt were only
around for the ride in other words it
could have been any kind of a political
movement it could have been any kind of
a party fortunately both of them were
very very tiny the problem was their
impact was substantial in terms of
undermining what we were doing I think
it's also important to point out for
history's sake that the it's these these
people did exist there are also actions
by our government to try to try to
incite this type of action and a lot of
nefarious programs by the government and
in that era to undermine protests Dalton
Texas and are under 450 line Dalton are
you there
yes I just wanted to think
mr. Clark for his service welcome alone
thank you
earlier this year Clark Welch won the
Distinguished Service Cross here in
Washington in the ceremony that you see
on your screen there David Maraniss let
me ask you hmm
why did it take 30 years before mr.
Welch to receive it
Clark Welch has been the most
underappreciated soldier in America for
the last 35 years said he earned a lot
of medals that for some odd reason and I
can't really explain it never quite got
to him the way they should have and his
entire career was marked by that but I
think you know what I I had all of the
letters that Clark wrote home to his
wife lacy during that year in 1967 and
time and time again he said that medals
weren't important that it was the action
itself that was important and I think
that defines Clark Welch more than any
medal he ever got mr. Welch
I unfortunately that there are there are
two reason I really did did not think
that the medals counted
I had read from when I was a young boy I
read about the soldiers who did what
they were supposed to do because it was
the right thing to do I'd read that
little thing that Napoleon said for a
little scrap of cloth you could get men
to cross a bridge and I I didn't pay
much attention to him and the other part
of it was that I expected the people who
were in the military whose job it was to
make sure that you got a medal or in
primarily in my case when I at the end
of every day when I would take a scrap
of paper perhaps a piece of the c-ration
box that the c-rations had come in and
write a note sometimes in my black
crayon that said today sergeant Jones
did a good thing I want him to get a
Bronze Star he threw to hang grenades
and then captured three people I want
him to get a Bronze Star and I'd signed
my name to it and I put it in the system
and I expected the people whose
responsibility it was to take care of
that to do their job the same way I was
out doing my job and they did they did
not now because of what David
covered in what general Shelton has
uncovered illuminated I am now able to
get some of these awards for the young
soldiers who should have kept them 36
years ago if I could add one more thing
to that so there were a lot of officers
who got medals they didn't deserve
including unfortunately the commanding
general of this division who got a
Silver Star for this battle and he was
not there well there was a tendency then
and perhaps throughout history I don't
know the answer to that part of it but
there was a tendency to give officers on
the rise medals that not really related
to any particular action this is this is
an email from Ed Hanson he's writes to
you mr. Meredith I am the son of chief
Hanson that you mentioned again in
passing I learned a lot about my father
and those awful days in Madison that
things he never would talk about I enjoy
reading the book in the coming week well
Ralph Hanson was the University police
chief during that era and I knew him
from my days in Madison but when I
started to do this book he was already
gone so I was not able to interview him
for the book and I really learned most
about him from the all of the documents
that his widow gave me from his life and
I never met Edie and thanked him for
writing Ralph Hansen had a relationship
with the students that was there was
probably better than most faculty
members you know when we ask the
what-ifs about that day if Ralph Hansen
had been allowed to maintain control of
the situation it's very possible that
the Dow recruiter would never have had
his interviews but more importantly that
the violence wouldn't have happened
and after the demonstration a number of
us were involved on all sides were
invited to go around medicine speaking
at churches and so on and Ralph Ralph
and I went out together on these these
forays and it started a relationship
that I was to have with him for years
tremendous amount of respect that I held
for for Ralph Hansen in terms of there
was somebody who was a leader Hampton
New Hampshire yes Clarke want me to tell
you don't tell him who you are I can
tell you Clarke is he's my personal hero
many others I think and one of the true
heroes that we have and I it's
unfortunate that everybody doesn't
doesn't have the opportunity to know
this is my nephew cousins are Wayne I
don't know his father served in World
War two is a enlisted fighter pilot and
then his father that went would have
worked for the CIA and the FBI and his
father died too early and I sort of took
over as a father figure although their
mother was very powerful so they didn't
need much help Wow and he and his
brother are two fine young men who have
grown up pretty good thank you Tim I
have two sons and I have four
grandchildren two little girls and two
little boys that I dearly love when you
when you talk about the women I I had
very little relationship with the women
in the army because my part of the army
did not have women in it I am I'm glad
that I got out of that business before I
had to worry about that I don't believe
women belong in the fighting
I had two sons wonderful sons who have
done well and now I have these
grandchildren I see these little girls
and it just makes everything quite
wonderful well I've got three three
teenage daughters so we wanted I've got
a handful but while we're on the subject
of women and I was thinking about this
from the last time we were on that
subject twenty minutes ago one of the
the characters in the book who I think
is very important for for what she
represents is is gene ponder I think
that that Dave dealt with with her very
gracefully and I think that that she you
know really opened up but when you think
about what she had to confront at this
time because she's about five to ten
years older than a lot of the
demonstrators and a lot of the people
she's really of the Eisenhower years and
there was a specific role for women at
that time and and she chose to challenge
it and under the worst of circumstances
and and I think there's there's there's
a lot to be said in terms of her as a
woman and and and that's something that
does come through the 60s a lot of women
who not only have to deal with the war
with the changing role of women and the
recognition that they don't necessarily
have to have their lives defined by by a
man I thought your wife was at home here
when you were obviously yes she was in
Florida with the two boys living close
to her mom and dad in Florida while I
was over there what what was her
reaction to reading the book in the in
the in the portion about gene ponder
she was very sympathetic to her I did
not know all of that story I learned two
things when I read David's book one that
general hay had given himself a Silver
Star and wasn't even present and my
first thought is don't believe it and I
said of course I believe it
and all the time and then the second
thing was the terrible terrible sad
tragic circumstances of Colonel Allen my
boss and his family which was falling
apart around him and the army gave him
no support I did not know the
circumstances until I read the book I
wanted to meet the Colonel's Widow last
week in Austin and was very much looking
forward to it my wife when she read that
part about Colonel Allen's wife
identified very closely with her and
said but you know to have three small
children and her husband goes off to the
it Nam and no support left for the woman
that Adam and has all the support the
support from his support fell apart
Olson very sympathetic and want to meet
with her and again for those who have
not read the book edging ponder it was
the what was then the wife of Terry
Allen and the mother of Consuelo Allen
who was a big part of the program that
you just saw and before this next call
there is a picture rather of Consuelo
Allen at age five and that is when her
father went away to work that's right he
was killed next call is from Seattle
Washington Thank You c-span it's an
honor to speak to you three gentlemen
who are undoubtedly a hundred percent
patriotic people and you know what we're
talking about as a world war ii support
lewis i would like to say that we were
very very under quipped world war two as
you gentlemen I'm sure know but a lot of
people don't realize that the same thing
with a quick Korea and then as far as
the members concerned the same thing
because it was no resolve so the one
thing I'd like this state is that the
first Gulf War was the best finest
quickest most thorough no battle eyes
read about throughout the history and it
was conducted for one reason perfect
because those in Manila station told
exactly what they wanted done with help
from the other nations
and gave the military every facet of the
military to go ahead and finish the job
and they cut their hands from what that
from the military let them do the job
was a hundred percent successful and if
people do the same thing but this Bush
we will next successful beyond all
expectations because we will have the
people behind them not be some of these
phonies that have been broke brainwashed
so thank you again gentlemen I hope that
happens I would like to be successful I
hope our country's successful Alaska
rather um hello I'm mr. Clark or mr.
Walsh I'm sorry just I just like to
thank you for your service my son is in
Iraq now serving and I hope he serves
this country as honorably as as you did
and mr. Soglin I have a question for you
I was only 10 years old in 1967 when all
of this unrest and protests was going on
and I lived in a college town in in the
Midwest and it was the one thing that I
absolutely cannot get out of my mind and
as a ten year old I understood was just
horrible was that some of these
protesters were spitting and throwing
rocks on returning troops and in my mind
I've never as a child understood it
happening I couldn't understand somebody
being in a college institution
institution setting so supposedly
educated behaving in that manner I
wonder if you could just comment on that
you know there are a lot of men that are
suffering from that thank you
earlier earlier there we talked a little
bit about keeping the crazies in check I
have never experienced or witnessed
anything like that
what would most of my friends and
and people I worked with were doing was
trying to welcome back vets and being
supportive of veterans who returned now
a lot of instances and is perfectly
understandable some of the veterans
weren't looking to us for that kind of
support but we started networking
particularly with some of the veteran
groups vets for peace and and and and
vets of that sort we also had mentioned
earlier in the program that I wished we
had a better understanding of the
soldiers and a better understanding of
our relationship to them because many of
us tried to be very supportive I mean
what we were trying to do was stop the
killing and a lot of us made individual
decisions I take this a little further
than the caller wants to go probably but
you know some people made a choice to go
to Canada others chose Jail some like
myself were willing to stand at one a
and then be classified 1a even though we
were entitled to student deferments and
took our chances and obviously a lot of
a lot of men were were drafted and and
sent sent to Vietnam
we who didn't go were spared a lot of
things and we know we were spared in
terms of risking our lives and being
killed but there's something else that
we were spared which was we were spared
having to make the kinds of decisions
that the soldiers made and having some
of the very awful choices that they had
to make in the battlefield and while we
focus while we focus on on the
life-and-death decisions there's also
some other decisions that are pretty big
which involve questions of human values
and questions of morals and we also know
that while there were some there were
some GIS there was fragging there was
use of marijuana as we got into the 70s
there
things of that sort it's an isolated
story about Vietnam and what's really
not told until we get to a book like
like this one is the tremendous heroism
and the tremendous anguish from those
battlefield decisions the I would like
to respond to the caller first that I
hope her son gets home well I hope your
son does his job and then comes home
safely I'll pray for that but did no one
no one ever spit on me part of that was
because when I returned I kind of hid
with the Army Rangers and I was around
people who I thought were just like me
I didn't have any medals and they hit
medals but I just thought that was the
way things were going but the to hit
Paul puts it much better they said get
rid of the crazies don't you can be
against the war but don't be against the
Warriors the Warriors are us virtually
every soldier I interviewed told a story
about some moment that that was
demoralizing for them when they got home
the spitting sort of becomes the symbol
for all of that I think I don't think it
happened every one of them but it's it's
almost like Jane Fonda being a
polarizing name the spitting incident is
what they all talk about and it just
reflects their feeling that when they
came home they were supported by this
country because of the unpopularity of
the war and and so they they felt
rejected and they were they were not
supported in another way that goes
beyond the protestors and I'm not
talking about the Congress and the
presidents exactly because that's the
part to me that I can't understand
that's the part that is is is how
somebody could support sending young men
and women into battle and then upon
their return not taking care of a whole
lot of things that are a consequence of
protecting this nation in in terms of we
know the obvious in terms of their the
you know the GI Bill and and and college
education and homes but there's also
there's so many health issues out there
now particularly for the vets who were
in their 50s and 60s that's and every
time I mean just walk watching Clark
here when everyone calls in and thanks
him for his service I know what he's
thinking it's what he wrote in the
description of these books he's thinking
about his voice that's all he ever talks
about Madison Wisconsin yes first of all
mr. Meredith congratulations on a great
book he said I wanted to ask mr.
Webster's been many people sir
congratulating you but I want to ask do
you feel any respect for the protestors
you and your men showed great physical
courage do you feel that the protesters
in the form of mr. Soglin and others
showed any moral courage that in the
long run prevented more days like that
awful afternoon you and your boys had
and do you respect them for that at all
which I may be a tough position for a
military man to take but I was just
curious as to your reaction to the
protesters at the time at 36 years ago I
didn't like or dislike them I think I
was quoted in a book home to my wife
which is absolutely right
I would take any one of my soldiers over
ten of those goddamn protesters well as
a matter of fact I would have and I
probably would today had given given the
task we had to carry out if I had to do
something that we were in Washington to
see if I had to accomplish something
here in the halls of these buildings I
would not want any of my boys here I
wouldn't want to be here I would want
Paul Soglin people who work who can take
care of that I had no anger towards them
36 years ago I didn't give them credit
for anything I knew that the boys I had
in my organization by the time they get
to me they had they had come through a
number of gates they weren't perhaps the
smartest men in the world and it's all
right I don't want anybody else to say
that about my guys but I can say that
I'd loved at them then I loved them now
but by the time they made it to my rifle
company they had already you know that
the people who were smart enough to be
peeled off to go to college or even once
they got to Vietnam were peeled off
working the PX and work in a
quartermaster by they time decay me they
were at the bottom of the pile just like
me and I love them I didn't care much
for the protesters one way or the other
now that I look back at it I never had
any animosity towards the protesters I
never had a hatred towards them I
certainly don't now I also never a
headache
I haven't had any hatred towards the
enemy I didn't allow my soldiers to call
him gooks or and he said I called him
the enemy I respected them I admired the
tough little bastards who could live in
the jungle didn't have any hatred
towards him I've had hatred towards our
leaders who have allowed us to my
wonderful soldiers don't always get the
leaders they deserve today 36 years ago
the protesters weren't a problem to me
20 minutes left in our program we're
talking about this new book they marched
into sunlight war in peace Vietnam in
America October 1967 it's written by
Pulitzer Prize winning author David
Mariners who's joining us this evening
with two of the characters from his book
Clarke Welch and Paul Soglin I want to
ask you mr. Meredith there are a couple
characters in your book that we haven't
talked about and going back to what we
were discussing before they are women
Oh who is Jane Bratton Jane Brotman was
a freshman at Wisconsin in 1967 part of
the large group of students who came
from the east coast to Wisconsin which
had a wonderful tradition of encouraging
students from all over the country to
come to this city and in the Midwest and
she arrived she was a naive freshman
sort of like me actually in that in that
moment and she she arrived with a whole
suitcase full of matching outfits and as
I say she saw her first Guatemalan
poncho and never unpacked but on the on
the morning of October 18th she was on
her way to a French review session in
the van HEIs building which is behind
Commerce building she watched as these
300 protesters marched up Bascom Hill
and went into the building and she
decided to stop for a few minutes just
to see what would happen
thinking that she already knew her
French and she could afford to miss a
little bit of the class and she watched
as the Madison police came with their
riot helmets and billy clubs and she
decided to stay and watched as the
police went into the building and the
students came out with bloody heads and
that day was an awakening for Jane
Brockman she still was uneasy about the
some of the strident rhetoric of the
leftist leaders a little bit leery of
the long hair but something awakened in
her mind and she went back to the
student union I wrote a letter home to
her parents about it that she was
starting to think about America and the
world and foreign policy and what was
napalm and what was dial chemical
company and what was Authority why why
what was going on that day I think that
for for thousands and millions of people
of my generation there were moments of
awakening if not that day some day
during those years and Jane Bratton
represents that in the story I tell in
the book who is Betty Menaka
Betty moniker was another freshman that
you're from Green Bay Wisconsin who came
down from a part of Wisconsin where
Madison was not thought of particularly
highly as sort of a hotbed of radicalism
and long hair and hippies and all that
her dad didn't want her to go said it
was a cesspool and she came down and was
actually in the Commerce building as the
riot unfolded around her she was in a
freshman English class and went out into
the hallway and saw everything that was
going on and actually was pushed against
a wall and saw the police dragging women
off by their hair and it was an
awakening for her as well we asked both
of that you asked both of them in your
interviews with them in Wisconsin about
how it changed them and we were there
let's show a little bit of that
I hated the consumer mentality of upper
middle-class suburban life in America
there was a part of me that was very it
was very embedded in me I mean as part
of me even though a part of me didn't
like it yeah so my mother had and I went
shopping for school clothes came out
here and she you know we went to
Bloomingdale's in New Jersey and we went
to Lord and Taylor I think it was and
got these outfits these fairly expensive
outfits you know like matching outfits
the sweater and and because I felt like
I was supposed to you know I had to wear
these things so I came after and the
first thing I saw is nobody who are
these clothes everybody wore jeans and
it was like such a wonderful wonderful
sigh of relief and I never wore those
gloves and it was it was just a
wonderful feeling it was like a feeling
of freedom of letting that stuff go
mm-hm when I come to the Student Union
at that time is specifically relating
this to the okay September right I
remember that there were tables before
you'd come into the Student Union you
know all different kinds of literature
of little literature and signing this
against the war and this has been super
act and this and because I really had
such suspicion of anyone who would ally
themselves with this at that time I
really I remember people Hawking young
socialist America you know newspapers
and said I wouldn't touch anything like
that I wouldn't go near a tape I mean
I'm embarrassed to confess
I'm a very curious person and so I had a
curiosity about these people so I would
listen to what these people were saying
but kind of stand far away you know I
wasn't gonna get too close
I might get contaminated but yeah I was
curious we considered part of the crew
ya know I was part of these people
seemed weird and strange to me but it
was just something that how could you
not have curiosity about this is a
phenomenon I had never experienced new
boring suburbia
okay when you look back on the 60s
dude are you glad you went through it oh
absolutely I mean oh absolutely I don't
know how long it would have taken me to
wake up the fire you know I may have
gave it as much I needed to
open up get smarter think about things
thank you I think that's the best thing
I think I used to take everything as it
was told me if it was by an
authoritative figure teacher parent boss
I accepted it you know I didn't even
know to question this whole process
really turned me into a person who
develop it touched something in me that
developed a kind of passion for learning
and a commitment to to always try and
learn and and be knowledgeable about
what's going on in the world and someone
instead of thinking of my country or my
you know you know identifying as a
junior in the world
become more of an internationalism who's
caring about seeing the world is rolling
this together and how can we help take
care of each other and you know you know
celebrate each other's differences and
learn about each other
David Meredith these were not major
characters in your book well I like to
think of every place in major character
but no I I particularly wanted to get
women into this book and because there
were no women directly involved in the
battle gene ponder Allen became a very
important figure to me as did her little
daughter Consuelo and on the Wisconsin
side as I said earlier the move the
anti-war movement in 67 was still sexist
essentially and so there weren't women
leaders that I could focus on but I
wanted to to capture what it was like
for a freshman woman that year and you
chose those two as the character Paul
Soglin what impact did women or anyone
like these women after seeing what
happened to you all in 1967 did they
have any impact on your movement
considerably I mean it really did change
things as we go into the the period I
think it's very important to understand
I I am to think that there's a four-day
period where were the world changes in
1968 Dave makes the point in the book
that all kinds of options were available
in 1967 and when go through the
president's decision on March 31st not
to
to to run that's the old 60s from 1960
through the spring of 1968 and then
comes the assassinations and everything
else everything changes in terms of race
in terms of gender gender I mean some of
it is much for the good some of it is
very tragic but the movement that takes
place from 1968 through the early 70s is
a very different movement it expands so
rapidly at that point it's it's a it's a
progressive expansion in terms of number
of people involved and women rapidly
moving into positions of authority back
to phone calls Waldorf Maryland go ahead
in our under 50 line yes I good evening
German and ladies I would like to us one
to welcome and appreciate mr. Clark
Welch
for the deeds and your contribution
thank you to the victory of American
soldier in Vietnam I recognize you but
that's all I appreciate as long as
myself as a former pilot of Republic of
Vietnam who trained in u.s. and go back
and find work and become period of you
for three years
let's get and come back to the state
that decision ship keep on my flight in
the star war program to have to defeat
communist bloc worldwide 58,000 soldier
and you and other combat leaving my soul
and honor forever the second thing I
would like to say is to the orders and
mister something you know what globally
and statically the American ideology is
always women we seen it now technically
on the field back in Vietnam we felt
just because the 300,000 Chinese
Communist support and when over into the
north
replacing the southern I mean the
northern Vietnamese Communist to win
over to throw and kill Wow we try to
associate that fight with the US allies
and other allies to defeat them you are
you were the protesters are the one who
step
in our back and we fail we are American
soldiers and thousand Vietnamese soldier
fight for the freedom of the world
especially the southern soldiers like us
we get no benefit with that nothing of
the world we are POWs we feel under
suppression and from the communists we
don't ask for benefit what we ask for
the honor us and the 58,000 so thank you
very much and I wish you all luck
after 13 years of learning this lesson I
have to cry thank you for your service
then I wanna make make two two
observations first that there were many
South Vietnamese as well as people of
other nationalities in Southeast Asia
who we basically abandoned who we had
enlisted for support during this period
secondly when we call and look at the
history of the period particularly prior
to 1965 64 whether we want to call it
faulty intelligence on our part or
simply mismanagement we did not
understand the nature of North Vietnam
the National Liberation Front and most
importantly we didn't understand who we
should have been supporting within South
Vietnam the the things we did to prop up
diem the things we did to fool not only
the Vietnamese but ourselves in terms of
who could really bring leadership and
support to a stable government there is
is is one of the great tragedies of the
war and so the the seeds of all of this
for both the Vietnamese people and for
the American people were planted going
back into the 50s in the early 60s and I
don't think we should ever forget that
it's as though when we started sending
those GIS to Vietnam when we started
engaging more South Vietnamese to
support us it's as though the train had
already left the station and and and we
were telling them it was there for them
Cleveland Ohio yeah I have a couple
points mister marinus this book you want
to peel a surprise for the book of by
Vince Lombardi you should have won you
should win feeling surprised for this
this is one of the better books I have
ever read second I read the Jim
Shelton's book and I think you amplify
on that third there are about four pages
in your book that talk about the
administration trying to figure out ways
to get good news out about what's
happening in Vietnam it's almost like
you take those four pages and figure out
what's happening today finally I was in
the first division in 1966 to 67 and I
was an infant in an infantry battalion
that worked with the 2nd of the 28th for
that year and I know many of the people
I know some of the people who are in
this particular battle one of my
problems with tactically with this is
that in the first division I saw us go
from a very hot shot where the where the
responsibility was really down at the
time we had didn't have much over
control on the part of the generals to
where in this battle we have a check
fire of the artillery for a half an hour
for the air to come in that didn't
happen you know about 10 of the months
that I was in there it was a it was a
tough fight that that the 2nd 28th was
in and probably a fight that could have
been better handled thank you very much
yeah it did obviously it could have been
better handle looking back at it now the
soldiers did nothing wrong
the soldiers did nothing wrong
but it could then better handle
davidmeredith of clarification you want
your holder for my story's articles on
Bill Clinton not for Vince Lombardi and
as to the other points that gentleman
was making I think it was clear in that
part of 1967 Lyndon Johnson was
desperately trying to show that they
were prevailing in Vietnam and that the
press was getting it wrong and there
definitely are echoes of that in the
last few weeks we have just about four
minutes left in our program we'll get in
two more calls Oklahoma City you're next
Oklahoma City go ahead yes Colonel Welch
god bless you and simplify and I'd like
to say can you hear me I can hear you I
know you're a marine well sir I just
like to say that I came back and I'm
having a hard time others came back late
65 and what I would like to know is to
the gentleman there that was with the
college right protesters I became a
policeman in Los Angeles in 1968 and I
served and fought on all the college
campuses the riots at UCLA Berkley Isla
Vista when they threw spit in my face
they peed on me
they threw all kinds of urine in our
face as policemen I you know all we ever
hear is about the poor students and what
they took
what about ask Jen tlemen that came home
proudly served over in Vietnam and then
proudly served our country for another
thirty years as a law enforcement
officer and can never get over what we
had to put up with by you protesters and
then I infiltrated the Communist Party
and the students for Democratic Society
and the Weathermen and let me tell you
they weren't just little students they
were radical left-wing leftist and a lot
of them right now are wearing suits and
ties and they're in our government
running our government so I just like to
hear what you have to say about those
poor innocent students
we have another hour i think i earlier
addressed some of the issues involving
what i referred to as the crazies i
think one of the points that goes that's
in day's book and goes beyond it is that
the 1960s are not something that's clear
and and you can even easily
compartmentalize people by who and what
they were there were very good police
officers there were police officers who
truly respected people's rights and did
not assert abuse there were police
officers who committed violations of
their oath who did not handle situations
appropriately there were other officers
who were sent into situations for which
they were ill-equipped and yell prepared
like some of the officers who were
involved in the Madison demonstrations
and officers involved in other places
around the country in terms of the most
radical of the students whether we're
talking SDS or whatever as long as they
are not participating in a violent
overthrow of this country they have got
every right to express themselves then
they have every right to express
themselves today and also still believe
that there is a right to peacefully
demonstrate there's a right to sit in as
a right to engage in civil disobedience
and there's rules that we both have to
follow the important question for the
future is are we capable of following
that was rules regardless of our
positions muskegon hello
you're on the air sir I have a question
I have a statement to make the
davidmeredith this is Ron Kramer dan
securities husband hi David I run I just
want to let you know that both of us
have finally read the book and you did
an outstanding job and
was we are on the path of finding peace
just like Clark way from getting just
the telegram delivered sikorsky's house
there'd be six years ago and we just
want to thank you very much and tell you
how much we appreciate it
how are you related to Danny Sikorsky
I'm Diane's husband so someday I want to
meet you and talk with you a picture of
Danny Sikorsky is now everyone is very
who is he
Danny Sikorsky was a number of Clarke's
Delta Company a young man from South
Milwaukee sort of a classic
working-class kid who entered the army
at age 19 and was killed in the battle
what do you remember about him I
remember he's one of the good little
kids I I knew I had it my little book
who he was I didn't I do not remember
him getting killed and I had a great
deal difficulty after the battle finding
out from the Army who had been killed
and who had not been killed I was
unconscious myself I regret terribly
that I was not able to participate in
letting the family know what had
happened rather than just getting a
telegram from the government and I want
desperately now to talk to her she was a
good boy a good young boy we are out of
time this is the book they marched into
sunlight by David marinus he's been
joined over the past hour and a half by
Troy the characters from his book